all right so we're going to go ahead and
get started right on time
So today we're going to be going over
how to choose the right database for
your application
my name is Zoe Steinkamp and I am a
developer Advocate at influx data which
is a Time series database company now
we're not just going to be going over
time series databases we're going to be
going over quite a ride range and this
topic will be kind of broad a little bit
in depth it's going to be kind of a
mixture of everything but most of us in
the audience here are probably
relatively familiar with how databases
work they store data it's real magical
um so we're going to kind of go into
some of the stuff that you guys might
not know some of these topics will
probably be things some of you guys
already know either way if you want to
ask me questions either here or later
you're welcome to find me on LinkedIn
So today we're going to be going over is
an overview of the database ecosystem
this year and honestly relatively within
the past like two or five years roughly
what actually makes different types of
databases perform differently from a
more technical perspective and when to
use a specialized database versus a more
general purpose database and when I say
general purpose I am somewhat referring
to SQL DBS
so some quick database history
SQL was initially developed at IBM by
three Engineers who were working at IBM
Donald Chamberlain and Raymond Boyce
they were learning about relational
models from another engineer a data
scientist at IBM called Ted cod in the
early 1970s they actually did Todd did
the sorry Cod did his research in the
1970s they actually developed SQL 1974
and in 1980. Siegel became the standard
language for relational databases and
these were the first original 10 things
that you could do with the database it
would be a few more years before we got
a few more capabilities but these were
the first original and personally
they're the ones I think we all probably
use the most I mean they were the first
10 for a reason
this is kind of a scope to look at how
databases have been coming over the
years so relational DBS have definitely
got a head start on everybody these days
they've started like I said roughly in
the 1980s they've been on the scene
since then morphing a little bit but the
big three have been around for a long
time MySQL Oracle and postgres
in the early 2000s or so the internet
got a little bit more complicated and a
little bit more fun specifically things
like images started to come onto the
well the images were already existing
but the amount of images needed to be
stored and the amount of data needed to
be stored
kind of started to get a little bit more
complicated in the fact that mongodb
which is a document database arrived on
the scene to start answering some of
those solutions to some of those
problems that people were having
graft EBS were really what gave us the
ability to do social media
so graphdbs are what powers underneath
things like Facebook which would have
come around this time as well it was
built up with graph DBS to allow them to
basically connect people we're going to
go into how that works but basically
it's what allows them to know what you
might be interested in who you might be
friends with it's why Facebook has such
a good way of guessing that you want to
be connected with somebody same thing
with LinkedIn they just weren't the
first ones to use it that's why I'm
talking about Facebook
time series databases came a little bit
later I started my company and Company
in 2019 they were founded in 2013 but
didn't really get like real funding real
status until around 2015 and we were
kind of one of the first ones on the
scene after that there's been quite a
few databases since then that focus on
time series and time series really came
around because mainly of iot devices in
in those use cases
and we're also going to talk a little
bit about the future DBS and the reason
I put a question mark next to Vector is
because it's the obvious big growing
future database but it is still
questionable you know you never know how
the cards will fall
so one thing I really quick want to
mention here and this is kind of a funny
thing and I'm guilty of doing it too
SQL is what we consider most relational
database Management Systems we tend to
call it a SQL DB without thinking about
the fact that SQL is also the language
to query those DBS so for people who I
actually did this that did this
presentation for a co-worker and they
weren't super technical they were just
there to be basically a guinea pig and
they were like I am really confused why
you keep calling it SQL but you claim
it's a language but you also claim it's
a database and nosql DBS can also
occasionally query SQL which is even
more confusing which is the case
although many nosql DBS have their own
querying languages which are normally
based off of SQL in some way shape or
form for anyone who's ever used like mql
from mongodb or cql from Cassandra DB
they even name them after SQL
practically
some nosql DBS can actually query with
the SQL language that we all know and
love
so just be aware that as I go through
this presentation I'm going to make that
same mistake where I talk about both
querying and the actual relational DBS
and this is just a cute little graphic
that kind of shows how some of them are
formed versus how the relational
database management system is formed
which we all are relatively familiar
with
these are the ranking scores uh from DB
engines as of January 2023 they update
this roughly every six months so we're
unfortunately like five days out from
the next one but basically for the most
part relational DBS are pretty pretty
popular this is not a presentation to
convince you that SQL DBS are going the
way of the dinosaur because that is 100
not the case they are the foundation for
most websites most applications and as
you can see they're extremely popular
and useful the other you know 20 I think
there's about yeah 10 different types
here take up a little bit of a chunk the
document stores being the next biggest
one because they've had to be honest the
longest time to grow that's mainly
thanks to things like mongodb
documentdbs are that big because they've
had you know a few more years to gain a
user base and in general to gain
functionality as well
another thing to note there are hover
400 databases on the DB engines which is
roughly a website that scores the
popularity rankings I don't even think
that's all the DBS in the world I am
almost certain it's nowhere close these
are just a few of the logos that I could
get onto this slide deck to show you how
many there are and all of these are very
different and how they handle data how
they store it some of them are a little
more similar than others you could argue
that MySQL and Oracle kind of live in
the same space Etc but there's just so
many so many databases we're not going
to get in depth per se on very many of
them I'm not comfortable going and
talking a ton of sorry I'm not
comfortable talking in depth about some
of these because I don't work for their
companies we will talk a little bit more
in depth about influx just because I
have the information and background to
do it but just be aware that when I
mention names like or redis or
something I'm not playing favorites I'm
just talking about the big ones that we
all kind of know and love
or at least are aware of maybe we don't
love them but we at least know the names
we know what they are roughly don't I
don't think I'm playing favorites when
it's time for you to choose your DB for
your application
please feel free to do your research and
choose a different one that I haven't
mentioned
so comparing and contrasting
so these are the major five things that
you look into normally when you're
looking at a database outside of is it a
documentdb or is it a graph DB like
these are kind of the things that
underneath makes them different
and I'm going to go into each one of
these there's also a few other fun
things like the cap theorem and acid and
stuff like that but there's also lots of
articles on the internet that claim that
those are relevant in the day of cloud
computing and I I just don't want to get
into it I don't have the energy for
those kind of fights so we're going to
focus on these main five things
so on disk storage format so you've got
pretty much two major storage formats
for your on-disk storage you have your
row base storage which does your data in
a row by row manner it's pretty normal
in most relational database Management
systems and it's pretty uh efficient for
the retrieval of complete rows making it
very suitable for transaction processing
systems now columnar storage formats are
more common within a nosql DB
environment they're great for
aggregating large data sets and they're
optimized for more like analytical
workflows so they're very good at better
compression improved
query performance like they just read a
little bit faster basically
the other thing is your primary index
data structure so most DBS always have a
primary index so that's normally what
you are querying on the primary key of
your table in SQL your T your primary
key is normally the ID on the table so
like customer one uh customer two order
oop order with ID of one when it comes
to a Time series database the primary
key is the timestamp because you
normally are querying based off time
that's kind of one like caveat that
makes that a little bit different is the
fact that the primary key is not an ID
like it would be in a SQL database which
makes it faster for querying time series
queries because that's the main thing
that we're querying and indexing off of
you can also occasionally have secondary
ones as well a secondary index is
normally created by you so that would be
where you say the most two important
things for me to query are my customers
IDs and the last time they logged in
because I'm using like a security system
or something or you know it's it's
whatever you want to create it as but
that's normally the second thing that it
will query off of just one thing to note
is that when you create those secondary
indexes
whenever you have to
do like a data modification like a table
modification that normally has to be
updated impacting that right performance
so some DBS do not offer uh secondary
indexing because of that reason
and also one thing to note the big
reason to have these different
structures is mainly to strike a balance
between the read and write performances
so it's really going to depend sometimes
you don't really get to pick this also
it's normally picked by the database
provider but some of them offer it and
some of them do not for that specific
reason
the other one that also has to do a lot
with read write performance is data
compression
so the thing is sometimes the better you
can press your data down the harder it
is to get it back out to do a
decompression so that can be a good and
a bad thing sometimes what you really do
want is a slower decompressor speed
because you just don't need that data
super fast you're maybe not monitoring
in real time maybe it's just somebody
logging into your website it's not a big
deal if it takes two seconds for you to
get all their user information for their
profile but sometimes it's not like that
sometimes it's you monitoring your
actual server infrastructure where
milliseconds do matter and you do want
real time you know data to stream right
back out for your monitoring Tools in
which case the compression algorithms
used for those databases don't normally
compress it as much so that way then you
can have that really really quick write
and read obviously the caveat on that is
that when you don't compress the data as
much it's towards a little bit bigger so
that's one of those problems with data
compression and every single database
company has their own they their
standard algorithms yeah for data
compression but most most of them have
it as a proprietary thing where they'll
tell you you know there's there's tests
that you can run against databases that
basically say like how much money will
save you because we can press your data
to this x amount that's all coming from
their internal algorithms
and another thing that's become
especially a lot more important in this
day and age is Hot and Cold Storage this
didn't this has always been a thing but
it didn't used to be as important as it
is nowadays because the amount of Cold
Storage has become so much larger like
there's just a lot more data to store at
this point like uh like the fact that I
can go on Amazon and see my orders from
like 2010 like that didn't used to be
per se a thing eventually your data just
like disappeared eventually they stopped
being willing to store it but nowadays
they just store it in Cold Storage as we
call it the cheap and deep so basically
how this works is hot storage is
normally faster it's more expensive for
sure and it's normally done in
solid-state drives or in-memory caches
so this is like an in-memory cache
database like redis
it's designed to accommodate that
frequently axed data or data that
requires a low latency access low
latency access so things like maybe a um
a shopping cart or something like that
on the other hand your cold storage is
normally a bit slower it's less
expensive like hard dress Dives or
archival storage it's more better for
people who are using their data for
analytical purposes and even sometimes
things like user information as well
basically it just depends but most
people are sitting obviously probably in
like the warm to hot category and then
for certain people they're definitely
storing in the cold storage and most DBS
nowadays offer some version of this
especially the major Cloud providers
and finally durability and Disaster
Recovery which might seem kind of silly
because you'd think almost all DBS
nowadays have some kind of durability
and disaster but that's actually not
always the case
um because it might cost them a bit more
to store your to store basically a
backup DB for you now what we normally
say though is that for Mission critical
data like your customer data for example
that's pretty Mission critical you
normally store that somewhere where
there is really good durability and
disaster recovery
by having a less by having less
durability constraints sometimes though
this can result in a faster right
through and lower latency making the
system more responsive for certain
workloads again this is more useful in
an analytical setting where you're
aggregating data but you're not super
concerned if there's a little bit of
data loss or a little bit of weirdness
or again maybe you're um maybe you're
monitoring your stuff at home you're
monitoring off home assistant or
something like that in which case you
don't care as much if the DB loses a
little bit of
and data along the way so you personally
don't set up your own durability and
Disaster Recovery because that's the
other thing too sometimes it's about how
you set it up not how the DB sets it up
so now we're going to go into standard
databases
so we're going to build our own little
company our own little e-commerce
website called Nordic Treasures it has
all the treasures that Norway has to
offer for us and basically our little
fictitious Online Marketplace is going
to grow and as it grows we're going to
add DBS to help it solve some of its
problems basically this is my Nordic
Amazon that I created so bear with me
because eCommerce is actually a great
example in using databases and how
they're used worldwide
so building the foundation so everyone
should already be aware of this but when
you build out the foundation you're
going to be using a relational SQL
database you're going to put in your
customer data their names their email
their address their history all that
good stuff their customer orders and the
inventory this is very basic obviously a
really Commerce website would have a bit
more than this but these are the three
basic things this is I can assure you
this is how Amazon started maybe they
had a few other things but this was the
beginning and at the time their
inventory was only books so it was even
easier
one thing to note is that SQL relational
databases should always be pre-designed
especially for those of us who have
learned the lesson when we do not
pre-design them
it's very very very important to
pre-design your SQL DBS they are very
difficult to change once they're
especially once they're in production I
suppose if you're in testing mode it's
not as big of a deal but there is entire
courses in classes online about SQL
database design and some of it's about
schemas but a lot of it's also about
like how the data should be separated
for faster querying and faster
performance
I'm sorry that this image is a little
bit blown up but it was kind of the best
I could like like this is an example for
as most of you guys have seen before a
very basic table here is designed the
user it's designed their user address to
be in a separate table and their user
payment to be in a separate one this
makes it easier to query and smaller
chunks as well which which is another
big thing I have been guilty when I was
very young and originally building my
first ever application and with a SQL DB
I would have put all this together
that's that's how I would have done it
because I didn't know what I was doing
and I was young and dumb and so I just
put all together and unshockingly my
queries took forever because I just put
it all in one big table it's not the way
you're supposed to do it
but I mean that's why there's a ton of
courses online for it nowadays that's
why it's taught in colleges
so scaling and personalization so we've
got our Nordic Treasures up we've got
some you know stuff coming in all of a
sudden though we kind of want to do a
little bit of scaling we want to have
more products we're very excited to have
more products and we also want some
personalization we want to be able to
recommend to customers other products
that we think that they will enjoy so we
can get more money out of them it's a
great strategy
so first things first when it comes to
item data if you think of a sweater
versus a jar of jam versus a sauna they
have very very different things they're
going to have different images they're
going to have different details in
particular the jar of jam might have
like where it's from it's probably not
going to have the color because you can
just see the image for it it might have
the ingredients but your sweater doesn't
really have that as much it might have
an ingredient of like wool or something
but it's going to have things like sizes
and the reviews are going to say things
like feeling like how does it feel on me
is it scratchy is it nice so that's
where documentdb start to come in here
so document databases are a lot more
flexible in how they handle data
aggregation which allows them to be a
lot better for these kind of products
for each single product is going to be
slightly different in its overall
details and flexible maybe at first we
started with just the basics for our Jam
Jar but all of a sudden people wanted to
know exactly where it was from and they
wanted to know the farm it was sourced
from and all these other things and that
was for all the products that was for
the sweater the artwork it doesn't
matter but basically as that expanded we
needed to be able to expand with it with
a SQL DB
this would be a little bit more tricky
because now we have to have a table for
jars of jam we have to have a table for
other food products heaven forbid the
other products that we're offering and
we would have to occasionally probably
delete and add things like maybe we lose
our Jam provider on the website so now
we just have this this erroneous table
full of jam information so documentdbs
are a lot better at nesting and
embedding this data so you can basically
have one Jam Jar at the top and then you
can embed all the details below this
also allows you to obviously be able to
easily delete them pop them off and add
new ones as you need to this is a lot
more flexible than working with the same
thing is the is with customer
recommendations so what that's doing is
it's aggregating out the purchase
history things like wish list and
browsing patterns and from there it's
creating a good picture of as most of us
know we've ever been on like a website
that recommends stuff to us hey this
user also bought this this product they
also like this product maybe you will
too that's all coming from normally a
document DB that's normally something
that the website is aggregated together
sometimes it's very much more specific
to you like hey I noticed through keep
browsing at this item that's that's like
a different one at the bottom of the
page but this one is the one of the
other users bought this and we think you
would like it is too like it as well
so for example
this is how this might look in a
relational DB you would have all these
different columns this is this is not my
like Jam Jar example this is like a
person so this is Mary and she has her
job description and a different table
and she has some of the app this is like
basically like a job description like
some of the work that she has done
before and these will all be in Separate
Tables
this is from mongodb so this is how it
would look in a document database so
this is all stored basically in a Json
object and so all the data is a little
bit more together and a little bit more
flexible like it'd be really easy for us
to delete the card that she has and add
a different one or change the year out
because maybe she made the mistake and
put in the wrong year
so that's one of the real highlights of
document databases is they're just
overall flexibility
fast and efficient searching so
most people here are pretty aware that
search engine databases power the
functionality that we get used to using
like keyword matching fuzzy search
relevant scoring obviously the biggest
search engines that we can think of are
things like Google and Bing which have
their own proprietary ones underneath
but most people in the world wide web
use elasticsearch it's one of the bigger
ones it's used by most of our favorite
Shopify companies like any like website
where you go to where at the top you can
search for the product that you desire
and it brings you back an actually
decent result list that's most likely
using something like elasticsearch and
that's not just for e-commerce websites
it's for lots of different searching
purposes like in academics as well like
you need to look for academic paper this
would be helpful or maybe you go to the
library and you need to find a book and
we also know nowadays we can also
normally tell when they're not using one
because it brings back really weird
results sometimes it just doesn't seem
to be doing it quite as we would expect
so obviously by adding in a search
engine we can go ahead and do things
like refine search results so now we can
get down to things like pricing and
rating and attributes that's everything
you know that you normally see whenever
you go shopping so you can be like I
only want to pay at most ten dollars I
want a five star item
Etc and I can also do keyword matching
like I only want cloudberry jam I don't
want to see your strawberry I just want
cloudberry
and then also technically a lot of
search engines also offer search engine
EBS also offer like analytics on top of
it things like being able to tell search
Behavior Trends and stuff like that
these are obviously really helpful more
on e-commerce side than it is for the
other ones I mentioned like libraries or
academics
and the way that search engines search
engine databases work is that they are
built on an inverted index so basically
what they're doing is they're receiving
and this one is receiving like a little
document basically just little poems and
it is pulling out the terms and
mentioning where it's found in either
document one document two or both
and it's keeping that record so this
works the same way in like a search it's
doing this exact same thing but with an
items details with pricing stuff like
that and so when it when you make that
search it's bringing back what it's
already determined to be in that
document if that all makes sense
obviously this is a really basic example
of how it works but I just kind of
wanted to highlight how this works on
the underside and this is more than
obviously just
documents it obviously works with mainly
item details and stuff like that to
actually do it with images is a little
bit different
enhanced performance so now we're
getting into in-memory databases so this
is going to be things like redis these
are ones that rely a lot on hot storage
they don't have a medium or cold really
they're just all in Cache memory
and these ones are especially useful in
larger applications that are growing and
have
I guess you could say more users and
more sessions more interaction basically
with the with the application or website
so in an e-commerce website this is like
the current browsing history and current
items in the cart so this is why like
obviously for a lot of people we're just
using like cookies like that's normally
how your shopping cart stays saved but
occasionally if you've ever been on like
a
like recently there was a ticket drop
for free tickets to Hong Kong kind of
deal that was using an in-memory cache
database to run that special because the
website got hit with like a million
people all trying to buy these free
tickets it's just like Taylor Swift
concerts you know
um and if it works well basically what
you do is you have in your in-memory
storage you have the amount of Taylor
Swift concert tickets you have and on
the other side you keep track of how
many users are trying to buy those
tickets and basically it's a real-time
thing it's real time it's sitting right
there ready to be you know pulled from
the cache it doesn't take very long and
this avoids stockouts this avoids what
what the Ticketmaster had to deal with
when nobody got the Taylor Swift tickets
that they wanted even though they were
sitting in line that's that's they
should consider using a better cash DB
for their problems but that's why in
general in memory databases are very
very useful like I said at a good high
scale where you can easily deal with
that cache data
but one thing to note is that it can be
more expensive it's stored within the
ram so it's not super cheap like we said
before the hot storage is not cheap and
it also has a risk of data loss this is
not where you store your important data
but this is where you store data
temporarily as you send it back to the
like you know relational or other
database that you're storing it in
like this so this is one example of
reticent use basically you're looking
into the cache and normally the cash
will return your data back to the client
as expected and if the cash doesn't find
it it goes and looks in the persistent
database so that's the one that will not
have data loss and will have more of a
medium storage not a hot storage
probably not a cold storage
I also really liked this image as well
when I found it I like that one of the
redis Clusters is just going out to go
find some gossip somewhere
and this is kind of a structure of an
in-memory cache databases yes you're
going to have multiple caches to deal
with multiple clients like I said
Ticketmaster needs to learn how to scale
this up so they don't have to deal with
Taylor Swift angrily tweeting at them
again
the new DBS on the Block
all right so we're going to talk a
little bit about time series databases
so time series databases address a few
major issues a high amount of data
streaming in at nanosecond Precision so
a really high write load iot devices
server infrastructure it's pretty noisy
it's very very heavy you could say
compression the ability to store this
large data set without breaking the bank
so in Time series databases compression
algorithms become really really
important because when you're dealing
with nanoseconds amount of data it gets
really big like it gets very a lot of
people come to us because they got a SQL
DB that's costing them hundreds of
dollars a month to store all this data
and it's really hard to get it out of
their sqldb into like their data
warehouse or data Lake somewhere like a
cold storage facility for them and it's
just it's out of control and that's
normally why they're looking at a time
series solution
cardinality the need to store wide rows
of timestamp data with multiple values
so sometimes your timestamp data is real
simple it's just like timestamp value of
temperature and then the actual
temperature value like 30 degrees
Celsius sometimes it's like a um it's
like an event or like a metric from your
infrastructure or a sorry I'm trying to
think of the word here
the Blackhawks um
I should remember this one it's what
Like Jaeger uses
um but basically there are certain cases
where it's not just going to be one
value it's going to be like 200. so the
ability to still compress that very
large amount of data and the one I've
already kind of mentioned which is
querying on time so instead of indexes
or values it's going to be queried on
that time stamp instead so with this on
our website it couldn't identify in
demand and trending items and
seasonality and one thing to note is
that some of these could be done on
other database types like a documentdb
would definitely claim that they could
do that and they probably could
tracking Revenue Trends to enable
pricing strategies same thing time
series database or another nosql both
would probably be okay in fact even a
SQL database could probably be good at
that and then tracking and monitoring
website performance which most of us
know because we're using some type of
datadog or other application that does
it for us most of them on the underside
are using some type of nosql Time series
database to actually store your data and
query it efficiently
another thing would be analyzing and
monitoring so this is more like the
physical side of things so this is
Warehouse iot devices which is one of
the biggest use cases for time series
databases robotics data shipment
tracking and inventory level tracking
these use cases are a bit beyond the
scope of our little e-commerce company
but they're still very important data
points to store and analyze and again
like I said the reason that time series
really came about is because of iot
devices like that was really the big
push to start storing this more
efficiently and being able to actually
real-time query it as well
and we've looked at kind of how storage
looks like in other types of DBS and
this is the basic one that I just kind
of mentioned you get a time stamp you
get field and tag sets and then you get
a measurement
so what that actually looks like I'm
going to go the next slide that looks
like this on a data organization
the database or some some time series
DBS call them buckets the database is
the very top level entity
the table is going to be the database
that contains one or more tables so you
can have more than one they represent
basically a measurement this one's doing
CPU and memory and then from there they
tend to partition and for us we store
these in parquet files that's why it
says parquet at the bottom every time
series database is slightly different
but most of them are doing some version
of obviously a database some version of
tabling and a version of partitioning to
allow for a higher compression rate
the next one is going to be graph DBS
so as I've already kind of mentioned
graft DBS are great for social network
integration so they're specifically
designed for relationship complexity to
be able to transverse different types of
relationships again this is what tells
you who you should be friends with on
Facebook or who LinkedIn suggests to you
to add if you've ever like if you're
like me and you get random emails that
says you should like start adding your
co-workers or whatever it's because your
co-worker probably recently just added
that they worked at your company and it
determined based off of that and the
fact that maybe your other co-workers
have already added them that they're a
good match for you too that's a graph DB
on the underside just making that
relationship and being like these five
people are are also added in this person
on LinkedIn and you are like these other
five people so we think you should add
them too which is also why sometimes you
get kind of random people you can just
start blaming basically your co-workers
or your friends for like the weird ads
you get and stuff it's all their fault
um flexibility it's normally schema free
data modeling that allows for enhanced
adaptability it's very similar to kind
of what we talked about with the
documentdbs except for even more a
little bit more crazy schema free and
the fact that yeah it's it's very very
flexible it allows for those contextual
insights like I mentioned before so you
can uncover patterns and this is also
where a lot of personalized
recommendations come in if you've ever
received like marketing emails from
shopping websites and stuff yes they're
normally referencing the cart that you
had or like the items that you browsed
but sometimes they're also using graft
DBS to get personalized recommendations
based off of other people like you
basically it depends on how much
information they have but that's again
where like a lot of the advertisements
on social media come from whether that's
scrolling through Instagram or scrolling
through Facebook anything that has
enough data on you to start being able
to map you will normally use this
and one that's really common that
doesn't really get a lot of attention is
anomaly detection
so if you've ever had like me a credit
card where like the somebody took the
numbers and now they started to rack up
some charges I actually funny enough got
a text the same day that somebody had
taken my card information at a
restaurant it's more common in the US
where they take your card away
um so somebody actually went and started
spending on my card that same day and
they texted me and they were like this
doesn't look like your spending pattern
it's not you is it and I was like no
that actually isn't me that's not me at
all and it wasn't super far away like it
was in my city where I lived it's just
that they had went to like a suit store
and Zoomies and something else and the
credit card had determined that that was
just not my spending pattern I guess
those weren't the stores that I was
considered to shop at and that's really
really common is that they're using
graftee bees for this anomaly detection
they're building a profile of you and
people like you and determining what
would be a normal spending pattern in an
unnormal spending pattern of course
they're doing also things like tracking
your location and stuff like that but
those are the those are the basic ways
of figuring out when your card was
stolen when it gets used like in a
country far far away but when it's more
closer to home they're using these
patterns for potential fraud and it's
beyond just credit cards it's your
banking in general is using this kind of
Technology on the back side
so for example this is how this would be
set up in a SQL DB you have your sales
your inventory and your customers
this is kind of how this starts to look
in a graph DB so you have your person
John who buys Pepsi and you have your
person Jack who also buys Pepsi and he
also buys club soda and he's married to
this other person so now we can start to
think about like maybe we should be
recommending to John that he also buys
club soda and maybe the person married
to Jack also wants to buy Pepsi and club
soda and now you can kind of start to
see how these relationships start to
form to start suggesting things to
people this is a very basic example but
it does kind of show how these
relationships start to form and again
the more information it has on you the
better it can start actually suggesting
things to you which is also why you
shouldn't let your friends use your
Amazon account because then it screws
out the algorithm and you get
recommendations for things you didn't
want
like I've had and this is the querying
language for neo4j which is a very
popular graphing database
and this is how it looks to query for
people for example with this one they're
named Emil and they want to know if they
know this other person Jim and this
other person Johann and basically what
this is going to do is give back a lot
of information about this one person and
the other people that they are aware of
knowing basically but it looks a it's
very interesting in how this looks and
how I will say this how readable it is
and I couldn't possibly not talk about
the wonderful Vector databases so Vector
DBS have been used for a few years now
for visual search so that's like if
you've ever you know taken a photo of a
dog or something and searched on Google
it would bring back images and search
results of that dog like if you took a
photo of a Sheba it would bring back
more shibas Etc that's normally all from
Vector databases
that allow you to integrate that visual
searching so you can look for specific
items with images but nowadays Vector
DBS get a lot more attention for the
fact that they can do uh they can enable
natural language processing by storing
word sentences documents semantic search
Etc and basically with that they can
start talking back to you as many of us
have been discovering in the past couple
of months this is very very powerful and
Vector databases have become without a
doubt like I said when the June report
for DB engines comes out Vector DBS will
be at the very top because these are
going to basically be enabling AI chat
Bots going forward in the future and
like we've learned with chat GPT they
will be a lot better and a lot stronger
and in the future they'll probably also
be customized to specific
to specific companies basically in the
future Amazon will be able to have their
own Vector DB or Nordic Treasures will
be able to have their own Vector DB and
they will be able to use that as
basically a chat that people will be
able to talk to and get help possibly
from I'm I'm not fully convinced how
helpful it's going to be yet we're going
to see how that goes but I will say that
I quite enjoy using chat GPT so I do
look forward to seeing how this goes in
the future
and basically how this works and I'm not
gonna go super in depth on this but
basically what they do is they take
unstructured data unstructured data kind
of like an image they throw it into deep
learning models and then you end up with
a bunch of vectors where you can get
that data out of it's very I suggest
everybody here go watch a YouTube video
about it I've read a few articles I've
watched it too I've watched plenty of
videos about this because I've got
friends who are working at Vector DB
companies and although I understand the
gist of it on the underside it still is
it's very confusing
which is okay because I'm not developing
it I suppose at least when it actually
gets to the end User it's a little bit
more straightforward milvis is an open
source Vector database that is available
so you can go check it out and use it
and basically what it does for people
automatically out of the box is things
like filtering user functions Vector
indexes Etc
basically they allow you to use it
without having to do a lot of the Dirty
Work yourself
so we have now built our Nordic
Treasures platform we've gone over quite
a few different database types and where
they would be most appropriate to be
used some of their better highlights now
one thing to note that I didn't get to
mention at the beginning which I was
supposed to was the fact that a lot of
databases especially big database
companies will claim that their database
can do it all
uh SQL DBS are very much they're
normally right about it but they're also
very guilty of this yes it's true that
quite a few DBS can do quite a lot of
things it's definitely the case it's why
it's so freaking confusing online is
because they all claim they can do all
the things but the certain ones are
better at certain things than others
which was kind of what I was hoping this
talk would help help everybody here
understand is some of the main features
where they really really shine basically
not the things that they technically can
do but the things that they are great at
doing
so two resources here are DB engines
which is what I've been mentioning a few
times like I said it's where you can
learn more about databases in general it
breaks it down into very easily
digestible tables so you can kind of
compare them and such the website itself
needs needs serious updating looks like
it's from like 2005 but it is very
informational the new stack is a nice
website for developers and people in
cloud cloud native environments to check
out they kind of talk about new
technologies and fun things that are
happening I went there for some of the
vector database information
and then a few other resources
so you can try it yourself if you ever
wanted to try a Time series database
inflex data is open source so you can go
ahead and check it out on GitHub and go
ahead and download it there and run it
locally not a big deal we also do have a
cloud platform it's free to use so you
can also go test it out there as well
further resources these are basically
pretty similar to what I just showed but
if you have any questions about this or
not just time series databases but this
presentation in general you can feel
free to join us in our slack Community I
can assure you that we have helped
people with other DBS outside of Time
series databases it comes with the
territory we also have our docs and
blogs and if you do really want to learn
more we also have a university which is
a free at your learn at your own pace
resource
and that is the end of my presentation
does anybody have any questions
all right then thank you guys so much
[Applause]